-Our first guest tonight is
an Emmy Award-winning actress
and director you know from
the hit comedy
"Parks and Recreation,"
the films "Mean Girls"
and "Wine Country,"
and, of course, her work
on "Saturday Night Live."
She directed the new
documentary, "Lucy and Desi,"
which premiers
tomorrow on Amazon Prime Video.
Please welcome back to the show
one of the best,
our very good friend
Amy Poehler, everybody!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Hello!
-Hi!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Hello, hello!
Oh, it's nice to be back.
-It is so nice to be back.
-And an audience, too.
-I know. Last time --
-Last time,
there was no audience.
-You did a few for us
with no audiences.
-Boy, it's really nice to see
those faces out there.
-It is good to see
human beings again.
-It really is.
-Yeah.
-I love human beings.
-Yeah, you've always.
That's one of the first things
we connected on.
-That's right.
We're like, "I love humans.
You love humans, too!"
-Remember, I was like,
"I can't believe it!"
A couple of anniversaries
just happened.
I can't believe it was
seven years since
"Parks" had its finale,
which is crazy
that that's seven years ago.
-Yeah.
-Eight years ago
since this show started,
and you were
our very first guest.
-I know. It was really exciting.
-Yes.
-I know.
And you had another guest,
and one of us became president.
-Yes.
-And it wasn't me.
-I always say --
I'm going to say it
every time you're here.
Guests on my first show
were you and Joe Biden.
-Yeah.
-And Joe Biden, we said,
"The only thing is,
I really want to
have Amy first."
And he was like,
"That sounds good to me."
And I got to be honest,
I think that speaks to a man
who has the first
female vice president,
putting the first black woman
on the Supreme Court,
and he let Amy Poehler
go first here.
-That's right.
Joe knows what I like.
-Joe knows what you like.
-Joe knows what I like.
I have a present
for you, though.
-Do you really?
-Yeah, because, you know,
the eighth anniversary
of something --
You know, you have to give,
like, paper or wood.
-Yeah.
-And eight is bronze.
-Okay. Is it really bronze
or are you making it up?
-I'm not. It's really bronze.
I looked it up, Seth.
-Okay.
-And so I got you a bronze
medal for all of your work.
-Did you really?
That's beautiful.
-Isn't that beautiful?
-It is.
-So just know that
you've been working hard
for eight years,
and you got the bronze.
-The bronze.
[ Cheers and applause ]
It's beautiful.
-Yeah.
-I love this.
-You know,
there's a study that says
that bronze medalists
are the happiest.
-Really?
-Yes, because gold medalists
have a lot of pressure,
and they think
they're going to win.
Silver medalists
are mad they didn't win.
And bronze people are like,
"I can't believe I'm up here."
-Yeah! That makes sense.
And then the rest of
your life, I feel like
if you're the silver,
if you tell someone you're
a silver medallist,
people will always say,
"How close were you?"
-Exactly. Exactly.
-Yeah.
-But bronze, it's like,
"I could have been eighth."
-Yeah. They're like,
"Do you know how bad
this could have been, sucker?"
-Yeah.
So, congrats on eight years.
-Last time I saw you, it was a
deeply fun couple of days.
We got to go to
Washington, D.C.,
because Lorne Michaels got
honored at the Kennedy Center.
-Yeah.
-And what was
really fun about it --
it was sort of
multi-generational "SNL" people.
We got to hang out backstage.
Do you have any other memories?
-Nope.
-Okay.
Let's just move on.
-They're just kind of like
a wash of people, right?
It was like, there were stairs.
There was some kind of carpet.
-Yeah.
-Joni Mitchell.
-Yeah. Yeah. That's great.
-Smokey Robinson.
-You should write a book
about this night.
-I should just do a book
that's just names and carpets
and -- It was so fun.
It was so fun to do it with you.
-Yeah.
-And it was -- What a night.
Don't remember anything from it.
Not because I was --
I wasn't drunk, none of that.
It's just now,
life is just like a watercolor.
-Oh, interesting.
So you've moved into
your watercolor period.
-I'm in more of,
like, my poetry phase,
where I'm like,
a name, a flower, a scent.
-Yeah.
-You know?
-That's really interesting,
because you were always --
-It is interesting.
[ Laughter ]
So, well, you had
a celebration recently.
-Yes.
-I know there's this
very tight group of women
who worked at "SNL"
at the same time.
You guys are on
a text chain
that you won't let me
look at or see.
-No. No boys allowed.
-No boys allowed.
But you guys had a birthday
party for you and Tina and --
-Me and Tina and Emily Spivey,
a writer on our show --
we all celebrated our
50th birthday
during the pandemic,
as a lot of people did,
so we didn't really get
a chance to have a party.
So we had a big bash together
just this week.
-And you guys all --
You know, you and Tina
knew each other before,
but you met Emily at "SNL."
Somebody made you a cake.
-Yeah, Rachel Dratch
made us a cake.
Rachel Dratch made us that cake.
And she made us video,
too, that was --
Oh, my God, did it make us bawl.
We had the best time.
And we did this Zoom thing
where we learned about
our enneagrams.
Does anyone know
about enneagrams?
[ Light cheering ]
-Okay, so more people
than I would have guessed.
-So, okay, well, there's things
outside your world, Seth.
But it's like a number that
is like --
It's like a personality test.
-Uh-huh.
-I made you take it.
-You did.
-You are a...
-3.
-Yes.
-Yeah.
[ Light cheering ]
-You got a couple 3s.
-Got a couple 3s in the house.
-And 3s,
from what I understand,
are driven,
ambitious, hard-working.
They're called "the achievers."
-Okay, I'll take it. Thank you.
-They're the talk-show hosts.
-Yeah. Okay, gotcha.
-And they work really hard,
and they're charming.
And we all
got -- We got our numbers
and we all found out
our numbers
and found out more
about our numbers.
-And, now, you believe --
If you could go back,
would you have wanted
to know everybody's number
before you started collaborating
with them at "SNL"?
-I actually think
it was really interesting,
because it kind of, like,
tells you what motivates you.
Like, 3s like a lot of praise,
like, "You're doing great
so far, Seth.
This is a great show.
You got your medal."
[ Cheers and applause ]
-We like our medal.
We like our medal.
-Yep, you got your medal.
And I'm an 8,
which is "the challenger."
-Whoo!
-8s!
So, I'm a challenger.
Like, safety and security
is important to me.
I want to know who is in charge.
And are you the person
in charge here?
-I mean,
I feel like I am today.
-Today. Okay, okay.
Good to know.
-Now, wait.
Does this mean that
this is just branding,
the 8 on my medal?
-Oh, my God!
I should wear this
'cause I'm an 8.
I didn't even think about that,
but, yes, it is about me.
-That's the thing,
because 8s are very
passive-aggressive
with their gift giving.
-Yes. They give you a gift,
and then you're like,
"Wait a minute.
It might look better on me."
-Classic 8.
-That's why it's an 8,
because it's like --
-3s and 8s love each other.
-Oh, no, I want to ask this.
Are we good?
Was it -- Would it make sense,
if you didn't know anything
about our styles,
if you were putting together
an "Update" duo, to say,
"Put a 3 and 8"?
-100%. Here's why.
Because 3s work really hard
and they want to achieve,
and 8s are like, "We got this."
And 3s are like,
"We don't have this."
I'm like, "We got this!"
-Oh, so, interesting.
The thing that you want to know,
who's in charge,
because you want to then --
Like, that means you are not,
then, in charge.
-Let me be clear.
I don't really know
what I'm talking about.
-Yeah.
-And I know there are people
that are much better
at explaining this,
but because I'm an 8,
I am already an expert.
Like, I think I'm an expert.
-Okay, gotcha.
-But what I believe to be true
is 8s like 3s.
They like hard work.
They like that. They like that.
That's where
they get a lot of self-esteem.
-Well, it sounds like
what I liked --
I mean, I could describe
it outside the number system,
but it seems like what I would
like about working with an 8 is
somebody who --
I get very stressful
about how things are going to
go, and doing "Update" with you,
you did have a vibe of like,
"We got this,"
which was exactly what I needed
before going onstage.
-Yeah. I think -- You know,
it was so interesting
to hear everybody's number
and also just to, like,
figure out
what motivates people,
like, how they like to work.
And, you know,
you read some numbers
and you're like,
"The emotional artist?
Like, oh, my God!
How do you get through the day?
Do you sit in
your feelings all day?
That must be nice."
Those are 4s.
No, but it was
really fun to do it
and it was fun
to do it with the ladies,
and we were
laughing really hard,
'cause it was explaining
all of us to a "T."
-That -- I wish
I would be there,
and one of these days,
you should allow boys.
-No, no boys allowed.
-Okay, great.
-Sorry.
-I do have
a lot more to ask you.
We'll be right back with more
from Amy Poehler.
-I'll just put my medal on.